an estimated 55 million meetings happen
at workplaces across the nation every
day 55 million a day one study shows
nine out of ten employees admit to
daydreaming during meetings John
Dickerson and another survey 47 percent
said having to attend too many meetings
is a number one time waster in New York
we have some working professionals their
opinions eight meetings is the most
meetings I've been in in one day I tend
to multitask during long meetings so
many people are call meetings and they
don't have an agenda ahead of time they
don't organize them the longest meeting
I think on average to be is thirty
minutes professor Stephen ro Goldberg
offers his advice in his new book the
surprise and science of meetings how you
can lead your team to peak performance
good morning to you professor good
morning and your book got jokes - a
meeting is an event where meetings where
minutes are taken in hours are wasted if
I die I hope it's during a staff meeting
because the transition to death would be
so subtle I'm pretty sure that dinosaurs
died out when they stop gathering food
and starting having meetings to discuss
gathering food so I thought I said this
professor is a good sense of humor but I
think you should starts with this why
are meetings so bad well 55 million
meetings as you noted and you know that
less than 20% of managers receive any
training on how to run a leading I'm
meeting anything you're doing a good job
we found in our research that when folks
leave a meeting there's one person who
feels like the meeting went very well
I'm shocked how many meetings are called
without a clear agenda or a time limit
with professionals with presidents of
organizations there are these just
habitual practices with meetings people
dial it in right they meet out of habit
they often defaulters to an hour meeting
because that's the setting the default
setting on a Google Calendar or Outlook
there's just not thought being given to
this topic you have some specific how
can you improve meetings yeah
yeah I mean that's what this book is
about what's exciting about this book is
that there is decades of research on
meetings and teams and this work can be
leveraged to fix this problem so tell us
yeah well well first step is get the
book and then even open after that it
really comes down to this leader having
a steward of others time mindset when a
leader fully embraces the idea that
there are steward of others time they're
gonna start making deliberate choices
they're gonna think carefully about who
needs to be at the meeting they're gonna
think carefully whether a meeting is
even needed and most importantly they're
gonna facilitate the meeting right
they're just not going to feature
themselves during the conversation
instead they're gonna try to bring out
the best in everyone to have a real
meaningful discourse not just to have an
agenda but to think about the agenda
beforehand to put some real thought into
it our research shows that having an
agenda in of itself actually does
nothing for meeting effectiveness it all
comes down to what's on that agenda did
the leader even make any effort to
solicit input from others and you say
that that smaller meetings tend to be
more effective why as meetings expand in
size dysfunction also expands and
there's lots of reasons right when you
have lots of people you have
communication issues but you also have
something called social loafing which is
the idea that the more people there that
are there they start to just kind of
blend into the crowd and that's where
the multitasking really I like that you
proposed standing meetings yeah and also
that President Obama Mark Zuckerberg
other people have walking meetings sure
I just want people to realize that
there's a lot of different ways of
having meetings and the time of the
meetings to you said 48 minutes but you
said Google has no more than 10 people
in a meeting Amazon has a to pizza rule
that if the meeting shouldn't be any
bigger than can feed to pizza it can the
meeting shouldn't have more people then
can eat two pizzas is what she's trying
to say right I mean the fact is we want
to keep meetings as lean as possible but
interestingly something that upsets
people just as much as having too many
means is not being invited to me
so therefore if we don't invite people
to meetings and do them that favor we
still have to keep them in the loop yeah
perhaps provide them with opportunities
in the beginning of the meeting to share
some input Thank You Steven yeah I don't
mind not being invited to really don't
Steven role Steve Monroe go Berkeley
thank you very much the name of the book
that he would like you to buy this is
surprising science of meetings it's on
sale now wherever you like to buy your
books Steven will join our daily
planning meeting this morning you are I
am I'm a daily planning meeting this
morning I didn't know that he'll share
his takeaways and tips on the CBS this
morning Facebook page
yeah we're not only report the news
we're also part of the news as well
they're gonna be our study yes